aerial attacks on Ukrainian cities
continue the U.S and its allies say
these are indiscriminate and Russia now
has and is using hundreds of
iranian-made drones it's called to order
in the security Council the U.S
ambassador says this is a violation of
the council's resolution that endorse
the Iran nuclear deal
United Nations must Implement Security
Council resolution
2231. we still have no explanation as to
why experts from the 2231 team have not
been dispatched to Ukraine to review
evidence of these weapons Origins and
the destruction these weapons have
caused
outside the chamber she was joined by
the ambassadors of France the UK Albania
and Ukraine they all believe it's a
matter of urgency for the UN to launch
an inquiry but there's a problem
Ambassador the Secretary General says he
doesn't have a mandate to investigate
what do you say to that
2231 resolution 2231 does give the
Secretary General a mandate to carry out
these investigations and we have all
encouraged the UN to move forward on
carrying out this investigations
immediately
the Russian ambassador to the U.N
Vaseline nabenzia had been waiting in
the wings listening to that
why not let the Secretary General do an
investigation if you've got nothing to
hide you've done nothing wrong you're
not using Iranian drones why don't you
have an investigation that would clear
Russia
as ourselves or the secretary yes why
shouldn't the Secretary General the new
neutral body a neutral body investigator
group and the group is does not consist
of experts but but the Secretary General
could constitute experts he can find
experts that should be should be done in
the context of bilateral relations with
Ukraine not through the security
security so you you want to block an
investigation you don't want anyone to
investors cannot do it within the
Mandate of 2231 that's it so we have
four Security Council Members three of
them permanent members who say the
Secretary General has the power to set
up an investigation and that he should
do so now and then you have Russia also
a permanent member that says he doesn't
have the authority under the existing
resolution and that there should be no
investigation it all puts the Secretary
General Antonio guterres in a very
difficult Place James Bay's Al Jazeera
of the United Nations